une veste verte bien reconnaissable et
le sourire aux lèvres la maraude peut
commencer pour l'équipe de nuit des
médiateurs de quartiers de Tours la
pluie est aussi de la partie donc les
Russes sont plutôt vides et les
rencontres se font rares en général on a
on a beaucoup de monde voilà qui est
comme intergénération qui reste
cosmopolite aussi des enfants surtout
pendant des périodes de vacances c'est
là où un moment donné où je crois ils se
retrouvent mais c'est vrai que cette
période d'intempéries fait que
aujourd'hui voilà on se retrouve pas
automatiquement là dessus du mardi au
samedi 9 médiateurs se relaient entre le
quartier du Sanitas et celui de Maryse
Bastié leur rôle apporté de la
tranquillité dans l'espace public faire
remonter les problèmes potentiels et
surtout créer du lien et une relation de
confiance avec les habitants
merci beaucoup bonne journée à mon cœur
c'est comme un lieu où il veut moi je
trouve il fait bon vivre c'est vivant
c'est voilà les gens sont hyper
accueillants hyper adorable voilà en
fait on surveille mais dans la
bienveillance ça on n'est pas là en
train de les réprimander quoi que ce
soit loin de vouloir remplacer les
forces de l'ordre ils sont des
intermédiaires qui ont eux aussi grandi
dans des quartiers prioritaires
l'occasion de faire cesser les a priori
les gens du Sanitas en fait les
personnes les enfants et tout ça ils
peuvent devenir des artistes il peut ils
peuvent devenir quelqu'un de bien tout
autant que que dans les autres quartiers
et franchement on a plein d'associations
qui font que on peut évoluer une
médiation mise en place depuis juillet
dernier et les premiers résultats sont
déjà très positifs comme le retour des
enfants à la ludothèque de la rotonde
les enseignants craignaient un petit peu
cette population qui a autour de la
rotonde on a su expliquer que
il fallait laisser passer les enfants et
puis qu'il y avait aucun problème
finalement et c'est pour nous une belle
victoire qui était pas pronostiquée qui
était pas annoncé des solutions trouvées
pour des rues plus apaisées les
médiateurs étant même leur champ
d'action depuis novembre à un nouveau
périmètre celui du quartier
Saint-François